cardi B she went live on Instagram with
uncle Bernie Bernie Sanders they talk
about everything right from his
endorsement of Joe Biden she was like
Medicare plan but it was Bernice the
state of his like nail beds that really
took the cake in the lab let's take a
look hi doing I'm good Carly I want you
to take a look at my nails how they
looking they're looking very quarantine
so you've been on quarantine for well
now nails but you know what it's okay
uncle Bernie okay I love this friendship
it's like an unlikely friendship that
has formed and I'm here for it and
they're so cute and I just I don't know
I love cardi has a lot a lot a lot of
fans yeah sure just like commitment to
like learning the political landscape
and just like informing herself
constantly is so inspiring really I mean
and it should be very vocal about her
support for Bernie love the last couple
months but also just politics in general
and I feel like at first because its
cardi B and she also she doesn't lose
the cárdenas right when she's talking
about anything really and so I feel like
people were quick to kind of like snap
judges like why are we listening to
cardi B but at some point and I can't
even tell you when I'm like she's
speaking some truth and I'm like
listening you know like I'm actually
like engaged with her and I'm like we
respect it I think we eat even asked her
once like whether or not she would ever
consider like a political runge I think
she said no but more than anything I
just love that she's kind of like she
she's speaking I feel like she's
speaking how I feel about things except
it's like way more direct and I'm just
like you better preach like i feel like
she's taking me to church yeah she like
puts things into a certain perspective
where you're like oh yes like thank you
for articulating how I'm feeling cardi
be like yeah and just also Bernie though
like getting in on it like the first
question for her is like hey what do you
think of my nails which I mean the
struggle is real I had to pry off all
mine but I think I found a solution
we're doing this on game they don't look
good in real life but through season
good wait what is that like this press
nails that I filed down and painted them
you're surviving and thriving because
I've got very crappy so many people I've
talked to so many women I should say who
do their nails they're like I can't show
my hands I miss getting my nails done
like that's the luxury that they miss
but you got you figure out the life back
your I talk with my my hand so I had to
I was like did you put these on just
read to you live at home knowing we're
gonna talk about cardi B in Bernie's
nails uh no but I did want to impress
pretty and you think you impressed me
okay so we've been talking a lot about
couples even single people like in
quarantine because I'll obviously and
I'm what you you moved in with your
boyfriend my boyfriend moved in with me
just for quarantine like just literally
since we've all been like social
distancing and self isolated and so it's
been an adjustment right I'm gonna be
talking a lot about that but I feel like
we haven't touched on our couples who
actually aren't spending this time
together who are maybe long-distance he
during quarantine and that's something
you have some perspective on because you
just talked to rosario Dawson he's doing
it yeah and it's something that you and
I were chatting about before is just how
now that we're talking to these
celebrities in our homes and we're in
our homes like the the Holy Guard that
comes with interviews is just gone
everybody is just very like open and
just like yeah I'm hanging out in my
house and here's what I'm doing like she
got up a few times so like those switch
things up and do things and it was just
like I really like hanging out with her
in her house yeah it was so real um but
you know like a lot of times we talked
to we talked with celebrities who aren't
as open to talking about their personal
lives and that's totally fine and like
we hit that wall and we're like okay not
doing that
it's kind of like it was just very
refreshing how open she is about her
relationship with Cory Booker and they
are not spending quarantined together
because she is with her family and he is
doing the stimulus stuff in Washington
yeah um when I was talking to her cuz me
my boyfriend were long-distance for a
long time and we had to find all these
like tips and tricks to stay connected
and you know keep our relationship
strong and I was we were just talking
about it I was like I have like
suggestions for you so many thousands of
miles apart it's so challenging and
and we're in April we were supposed to
have our longest vacation ever
you know just time period together
because he's been you know campaigning
the whole year I mean you just and it
was just only a couple months into our
dating so we've not really had a really
good chunk of time together because of
our work and our family and all of the
other things so it ended up being what
was supposed to be our longest time
together now our longest period apart
from each other so that's definitely
been really challenging but we've been
you know watching briar patch and kind
of catching up with each other on it and
different shows
otherwise it's we're reading to each
other we're try to cook together you
know what a lot of people are doing it's
kind of estranged from each other right
now yeah I mean a lot of couples are in
this situation like I was you know
long-distance with my boyfriend for two
years we finally lived together but my
favorite thing to do is we would start a
movie at the same time and watch it on
FaceTime is very creative things we've
been talking about like yeah we're
picking the next show after briar
patches done
that's kind of amazing and also like
just because just imagining I also feel
like you were ahead of the time like
everyone now is doing like Netflix party
and stuff but like you literally would
have like your phone and your laptop up
so you guys could like actually interact
at the same time was she is this
something that was driving her crazy
like does she miss Cory
yeah because she said that they so
they've been long-distance for a while
like you know he was obviously like
running for president she was shooting
whatever she's shooting she's constantly
has something in the works and they were
planning on having this like big long
summer vacation together and then
closing the gap at some point soon and
it looks like that's all getting kind of
pushed to the side so it she was a
little bit like oh like we're about to
have like all this time together that
just got like take it away
we'll help all those couples out there
who are social distancing without their
partner what were the tips you laid down
for were a couple like some tips and
advice for people who are you know a
long-distance gosh I would say the
FaceTime thing is like super was super
strong for us like you can text all day
but it's like having that connection and
just like hanging out together
like if you play video games we would
literally like set up FaceTime both play
our own video game but just like hang
out and talk to each other so it wasn't
like we had this time where we had to
like sit there and talk and then the
conversation would end ten minutes later
is like we would hang out for hours and
like obviously if you have Wi-Fi mmm
that doesn't cut into your plan you can
just FaceTime through Wi-Fi so that's a
really important one that and yeah
just kind of like coordinating your day
together in a weird way yeah and
connecting constantly as well how's the
adjustment Ben if you don't mind me
asking
no fast forward to now we're obviously
you guys do live together and you live
together before we were all quarantine
but now there's like you're stuck at
home essentially there's nowhere else to
go
how's that going for you well I we live
in a one-bedroom apartment so it's not
like we have these separate rooms to
really hang out and it's like the bed in
the couch and that's it and the weirdest
I mean the hardest adjustment I think
has just been like we I mean you and I
we're at work for over ten hours a day
it was barely home like I came home for
dinner and sleeping and that's really it
so now we've gone from like a few hours
together a day to 24/7 so it's just kind
of like for us it's just been adjusting
like how to navigate each other's
because it's hard to bring your work
brain into your home brain oh my god you
know what I mean like I put it off too
yes and there's it's where's the line of
like where do I switch off my work mind
and go back into my home life mine
because my home was like I left work at
work I came home and home is home and
now they're both in the same location so
it's he's just kind of manager only
stress really really and you have to
take it one day at a time I feel like at
the beginning of this we didn't know how
long we would actually have to be at
home and so I feel like oh okay these
little things are bothering me whatever
i'ma let it go but then now that work
week five when we've gotten to about the
mid May to stay at home now I'm like
okay no we gotta figure this out
yeah just like it takes a look it's so
funny if I feel like it takes a little
bit of compromise but also like speaking
up and communicating about like what's
bothering you because you're right this
800 square foot space is not big enough
but there's only so many places you can
go you know so
I've been focusing on my bedroom I've
been turned into a sanctuary and that
has been the best project I'm having so
much fun like designing it and then it's
something that he's helping me with to
now so it's coming in you come in his
face too while the living room is still
my studio you know home studio because
you know I'm still shooting videos for
yeah yeah it's been such a weird time
but also us as weird as it is I keep
saying it's special cuz it's like
helping you figure that stuff out now
yeah I think I mean having an open
dialogue with your partner is the most
important thing if you can talk about
anything no matter how awkward or weird
it is like I mean we haven't even
established like rules not really rules
but it's like whoever cooks the other
person is doing the dishes and yeah
always did like use a dish clean the
dish like that kind of stuff that we
just never had to like deal with before
because it's such tight quarters and
everything gets messy so fast and I am
if you can't agree on what shows to
watch this buy a second TV that's what I
did oh oh my gosh I should show you um
yes I got ya do it good so we have we
have brought out my TV from the bedroom
and put it here yeah and then we've the
main TV so that we can both play video
games at the same time and like the
other person doesn't have like watch the
other person play video is it separate
video games you guys are played yeah
he'll be playing like Call of Duty or
sometimes the quite same game
[Music]
yesterday we were talking about this
viral video of this family from
Washington if the Heller family it's a
family of six who to preoccupy
themselves they actually recreated
journeys 1983 video separate ways well
little did you know we actually got to
talk to them via videoconferencing about
that epic viral video here's they had to
say
I just fun to redo like a music video it
was funny because our son Jackson we
only I think got him to do it cuz he
said nobody's really gonna see this
right and I said no no no I probably
watched a hundred different videos
mostly in the 80s because their videos
are a little simpler yeah people we
haven't heard from in years it was like
we saw you it was awesome it was it's
been it's been a cool way to reconnect
to some people yeah I think if the goal
is just you know find creative ways to
to do something I mean I'm not you know
video is not for everybody I think we
have a unique opportunity now because
we're forced me together more than ever
find something that you can all do
together and we kind of got lucky it's
something that we'll be able to look
back on year after year after year and
like their kids they'll be able to show
look we did with their parents you know
during this really weird time in history
we put this one thing out there this
crazy thing happened with it and if
that's all that comes of it like that's
totally fine we haven't heard from Steve
Perry up dude
all I'm saying is like people families
celebrities everyone they're getting
creative and I'm just wait I need to
recreate a music video over here because
I'm getting starting to get a little
more look I'm on that books all the time
it's a scary time
it's an anxious time I don't want to
take away from that but it's also this
like wave of content yeah is so great
like tick tock is arriving right now and
the recreations I myself I know we've
been mentioned on et Levis yeah but I've
been recreating Jim Carrey the people
need me the bet that was impressive and
not just Jim Carrey videos but like from
liar liar' right yeah my favorite my
favorite movie Computer Society or so
like contributions like I'm like I got
to give back how do I get back I'm just
gonna recreate liar liar people will
love it it's very violent a boy must
grow to be a warrior there's a need for
it like you just said like the wave of
content people are paying attention I
have never cared more in my life about
what people are eating in the past I'm
like I don't care what your cool you
cooked bread good job but now I'm like
you impressive like you did that in this
time I think people need it and you're
one to talk because those liar liar' lip
tubs that you've been doing have gone
viral like the people are actually
watching and engaging with that are you
tripping out on that kind of because I
like I posted them on tick-tock without
having a tick-tock prior so now that
they've like gotten a lot of views at
this point the comments are just so
funny because but you're so good at them
and his lines and liar liar because Jim
Carrey there are mile a minute
remember every word and you're literally
or matching it with him I'm impressed
girl I want to talk about what music or
what artists are you discovering or like
listening to for the first time in
quarantine because again we have the
time like I know a lot of people are
watching movies they never watched
before hopping on bandwagons when it
comes to TV shows that are popular but
now let's talk about music what are you
listening to uh Danny you're gonna
you're gonna flip what I have been
studying BTS sell me alarms barley yo
you okay I'm you know I know the army is
watching this hello I am joining you now
so bear with me while I say like very
basic things from like the beginning of
your fanship but I started watching
there I was watching one of their videos
because they're very like colorful and
young to watch um but I was like man
their dance moves are so good and then I
got so invested in all their choreo so I
started watching all their live
performances which I don't on
Stan no one misses a beat there's not a
second there's not a flaw yeah it what
every time exactly
and so I just went down this huge
YouTube wormhole and I was like I'm
gonna learn all their names I'm gonna
and I think I like I've nailed it like
you show me a video I'm like boom which
that's always easy sugar yeah like I got
it I love it I love that you're
embracing them because they are insane
like obviously I was only introduced
them to be very beginning because I was
about to interview them like their first
like big us interview and I literally
easily became a stand the army is
amazing and you talk about their live
performances when I finally got to see
them live because I because I
interviewed them twice before I actually
got to see them in concert I was like oh
no no they're like actually talented
yeah I just sing and dance at the same
time and they each got their own vibe
but together oh my god it is wild I
showed well I actually watched her
interview again but you did with them
because I was trying to show like we
were we were very curious about what
their actual person like their
personalities are because really get
that from their videos and I was like oh
like I think like j-hope is like goofy
thank you
RM does a lot of the talking because he
he speaks the most English yeah like I
was like so you'll probably like connect
with are on that first but like then you
know you kind of get like j-hope is just
such a goofball I think okay good I'm
still learning but know even some of the
quiet ones those are the ones I fell in
love with my favorite now my bias as the
fans call it is Jimin like Jimin is not
like first of all he's one of them he
vocals amazing but also he's got this
like sweet demeanor and he got to really
shine during James Corden carpool
karaoke if you guys haven't watched it
do it but it sounds like you really did
fall down a beat I think Jen is quite
handsome yes Jong Kook Jong Kook stands
up to but I just have to say welcome to
the army oh thank you thank you me I'm
gonna watch the documentary because I
have not and you just told me about it
and I didn't even know it existed and
then my dear one I like I have to
mention Julie pose new album because I
can't stop listening to it it is one of
the best albums like that I've heard in
a long
I'm probably like Ariana's thank you
next oh that is really solid comparison
ya know and I just I'm thankful because
I know had leaked which I didn't listen
to it until she released it but then she
didn't respect gotta respect the art you
know and I plus I want to hear like the
actual studio recording but she even
said that she almost debated not putting
it out thank God she did she even
released it earlier than expected and I
was I still remember that weekend I was
I'm still bumping it from the day she
actually dropped the album and it is a
Bob Grammys 2021 watch out like it's
gonna be fired
i I've been listening on a repeat and
also listening and educating myself on
tame impala
you know tame impala yes I do yes yes
yes psychedelic psychedelic rock band I
listen to them at Coachella because I'm
there with friends who listen to them
but I'm like going through their
discography people been sleeping on them
okay they're very like niche fanbase and
like a lot of fans but you know main
main main stream it's just not there yet
so but every time I hear a team impalas
on I'm like that's damnable like huge
exactly they're there no there it's a
very specific sound and I'm so glad they
exist seriously so BTS team and Paula do
a Lipa what are you guys listening to
let us know well let's get into video
games I'm not alive I'm not a gamer I
have an Xbox one never played a game on
it that's literally how I watch my TV
but the game everyone's talking about is
Animal Crossing which I'm realizing is
actually like just the latest version of
this existing franchise right so it was
a game I don't know if you have a year
hand in 2002 doesn't - yeah I played it
on GameCube and then they did like a
mobile game like a year or two ago that
was like I'm is similar but it was like
it was satiating for the fans but then
they just released like a brand new
version of this game that is completely
like updated and wonderful and I've
played like a hundred eighty hours of it
so far it's taken over your life like
that Nintendo switch tells you your
hours and it also tells everyone you're
friends with the amount you played
it'll be like Ash Crossin 180 plus hours
of animal crossing and I'm like don't
call me oh you're not alone everyone is
playing this game it's so much in fact
that like literally it's hard to find a
Nintendo switch now it's getting harder
to find that hand sanitizer and like
Clorox wipes like those are flying off
the shelves so uh what is it for those
of us like me who don't know what Animal
Crossing is how do you play and like why
are people obsessed with it okay I'm
gonna preface this when I describe it
you're gonna be like why does anyone
play this because it's gonna sound very
boring but it's not so you are a human
that lives on this deserted island with
like a couple of animals and there's
this guy Tom Nook and well he's not a
guy he's like he's a raccoon nah
and he's like here's your house you owe
me 60,000 bills which is the currency
yeah um so you have to do things to like
pay back your loan so you like fish and
catch bugs and cat get some fruit and
sell it at the store and then you'll get
bells and then you eventually pay them
back but it's all in real time okay so
once you pay back then the next day your
house expands and then you get like a
new store that comes along and then like
oh you got to build this campsite and
there's also like a museum and you want
to like fill the museum with all the
fish and bugs and fossils but like every
day I want to log on because the day the
night before or the day before I've done
something that will be updated the next
day so let's log on and see my new like
yeah I'm and where I put it and all this
stuff so yeah it's hard to explain
without it sounding so snoozy no I would
describe it as like look we all feel
very anxious right now I didn't just
like a like a video game xanax
yeah it's called anxiety imagine that
that's yeah it's very calming very
soothing if you like the Sims and you
play the sims yeah this if you like to
spend most of your time on the Sims
building the house and doing like the
build mode stuff it's essentially what
this game is honestly even if I wanted
to play I couldn't like I can't I went
to Target yesterday for the first time
in quarantine and there's a sinus as
well
sanitizing wipes and Nintendo switch
like it's just there's no way I'm gonna
be able to play it I talked our own
Katie Kraus into getting Animal Crossing
and I think she got like one of the last
ones because we were like looking at all
targets and which ones you could pick up
you couldn't even get the regular switch
you had to get the Nintendo switch
flight which is still great um you just
can't play it on your cute little do it
business is booming for Nintendo switch
hair clippers flower apparently
someone's baking the baking aisle at the
grocery store I'm like oh and of course
paper towels and toilet paper but now
that's where a different et live at home
that's for a different episode in a
different show until then ah I miss you
so much
I love it I got right I'm like we could
talk all day guys so we'll do that
offline but thank you so much for
joining us and thank you guys for
watching reminder we are still pumping
up content over at ET online.com
including ash crossings interview with
rosario Dawson she also spilled some
Star Wars tea so make sure you guys go
check it out then and also follow us on
tic toc because if you need some
entertainment some quality content there
it is right there for ya oh gosh what a
plug I loved it alright I'll see you
next time and we'll see you guys
tomorrow
[Music]